foreign
[Music]
thanks for watching the pretty intense
podcast today on the show is Stephanie
Lynn I've been following Stephanie's
work on YouTube for a really long time
she talks a lot about narcissism and
codependency and personality disorders
and red flags and all kinds of various
different things and but she's a she's a
coach as well a relationship coach she
has over a half a million subscribers to
her YouTube page so just go check it out
she has tons of content so we we did
touch on personality disorders and what
kind of develops them but what I wanted
to know more so is like how do we not
become a match for that like how do we
become the one the person like how do we
become the solution to what manifestes
problems in front of us with a partner
and with being triggered it was like a
great Deep dive on just like the self
and how critical it is to develop the
relationship with yourself with your
inner child and check in and really
really use that relationship as your
number one relationship that you check
with every day and we talked about that
we talked about relationships sex we
talked about uh chemistry compatibility
you know all kinds of really really
great topics that I feel like people
will be curious about so enjoy the
episode please hit subscribe and the
bell for the notifications when we have
an episode come out and please let me
know in the comments what you think I'm
curious what resonated with you the most
in this episode so I've been watching
your videos on YouTube for so long
really oh it's so great I think I
started in like 2017. I mean you've
killed it you've killed it girl I'm so
excited there was one year honestly it
was 2020 that I think kind of just
pandemic and people were just trapped
and left in their own devices and you
know so it was it's been really good
it's been fulfilling and now it's
starting to evolve into like different
things too like entrepreneurship and I
feel like as I evolve I'm like I want
you guys to come with me like you know
we don't want to always be talking about
like the negative stuff like let's focus
on like good stuff yeah we're gonna do
some of that why do you think I'm
curious why you think maybe 2020 was the
reason other than obviously people being
in their houses like what is the more
psychological reason that could have
pushed people into wanting to consume
more of your content
I don't know I think honestly being
stuck in the house and not being able to
do the normal or not have the normal
distractions that I think a lot of
people had it kind of brings everything
to the surface like traumas and wounds
and really looking at your relationship
you know those kind of things so I think
that probably was the reason why yeah so
did your content come from being
um from a profession from going to
school from being a counselor
psychiatrist nope it was our experience
yeah so I was married to someone who I
Dean definitely has narcissistic traits
and I kind of started with that but it
started even before that relationship
with just understanding codependency and
being like Oh you think I'm codependent
understanding childhood trauma and
emotional wounds and being highly
sensitive and an empath and it kind of
just Law of Attraction and then it kind
of just started to just evolve into to
like everything that I talk about
yeah there's something
very unique about the experience of
being with a narcissist that I'm not
sure if you do you think it's even
possible to really comprehend it and
understand it if you haven't had the
experience I agree why is it I don't
think so and I you know because it's not
like any other relationship and I I
think when you talk about it with people
that have never been in it it's it's
just it's really hard to understand you
know it's more than just like oh they're
a little unhealthy or they have these
toxic traits it goes so deeper than that
yeah and it's so nuanced there's so many
little things like like you know just
something like getting like when they
don't look at you at a party the whole
night it nothing looks wrong but yet
they don't show you any attention they
don't look at you or you know the sort
of
seemingly helpful
backstabbing compliments of like oh you
just need to love yourself more you know
and you just like it's like it's like a
thousand knives and those are things
that we're not taught
you know like no one teaches us about
those kind of things and I think if you
come from a place where you have your
own stuff and you don't understand like
the educational part of it you don't
understand psychology you don't
understand you know emotional abuse and
gaslighting and manipulation and all of
those kind of terms that like no one you
know Mom and Dad don't sit at the dinner
table teaching you that stuff that if
you don't know it and you're you don't
feel healthy within your own self you're
just you're not going to really see it
until you just can't not see it anymore
I want to try and see how we can not be
a candidate for those relationships so
maybe let's start by just even because
sometimes there's some context within a
family you know you hear about or you
hear from your partner like what their
parents were like or how they refer to
them their experiences so what is it
that is in the parental unit
that creates a narcissist and then I
also want to talk about a codependent
because they're not all that much
different no they're not actually that's
really a point
um they're actually two very similar
people they just get what they need in
different ways right you know so a
codependent is typically raised by
someone who was emotionally abusive or
emotionally unavailable doesn't mean
that our parents are bad it just means
that they were doing the best that they
can do right and so a narcissist is
usually
raised by a narcissist or someone who
could possibly be codependent as well
just very much enables the behavior so
it's it I always found this part so
interesting so you're telling me that
two people can be raised by the same
parents and one turns out to be
narcissistic and one turns out to be
codependent like and that's something
that I don't really think we can explain
it just has to more so do with the child
and just kind of like what direction do
they go in yeah sensitivities of the
child or what the child needs and what
they're not able to really give
themselves will kind of determine what
direction they go in what are some ways
that someone would describe their
parents if they had that kind of
childhood or psychological abuse to some
degree both a codependent parent and a
narcissistic parent can both be damaging
in their own ways so it really you know
if you're looking at like a narcissistic
parent it kind of varies it could be
someone who's keeping up with the
Joneses someone who values achievement
over the connection that they really
have the child it's really that parent's
inability to connect on an emotional
level with a child where I can actually
see you where I want to know more about
you what do you think how do you feel
inside just having that kind of like
validation and being able to soothe you
and really honor what you think and feel
even as a very young child you know
um
100 and that that really determines how
healthy a person really grows up to be
is whether or not they can really
connect emotionally with one or both of
their parents and we all have that one
parent that we tended to kind of
gravitate more towards or we connected
more towards with that parent usually
that's the parent that kind of saw us
what is it what is the pathway to not
being a match to that what is the work
that needs to be done like how early do
you need to start like how do we how do
we just not find ourselves in immune an
emotionally abusive relationships I
think
for me that's that was like really huge
like like I said understanding what is
narcissism what is codependency what is
emotional abuse what is manipulation
like understanding all those things even
little things like we understand smaller
ones like oh she's being passive
regressive or oh they're giving me the
silent treatment like those things are a
little easier to understand but
understanding what boundaries look like
what does it look like when someone
violates a boundary how do I even honor
my own self how do I listen to myself
how do I have this really great
relationship with myself because that
really will determine you know every
relationship that you have is how do I
feel when I'm around this person am I
looking for this person to save me am I
looking for this person to validate me
am I looking for this person to make me
feel something that I didn't feel prior
to going into this relationship
yeah yeah what was your journey with
boundaries I'm curious
like because I'm guessing you were more
codependent is that right I definitely
more codependent it's weird weird
because I actually
had to do something I wasn't gonna do it
okay you know I wasn't that kind of
wishing I think it was more just
listening to my own intuition and going
off of how I felt around people to
decide whether or not they were just
good for me not that they were like
horrible people either not every person
is like the worst person in the world
and we cannot be around them whatsoever
some people are just a little unhealthy
some people just have traits that just
aren't the best and it's kind of their
own defense mechanism of how they deal
with uncomfortable feelings that they
feel so anyone that is emotional abusive
I mean we and we've all done it we've
all been a little passive aggressive or
a little whatever but do we are we doing
it consistently and when we do do it do
we Spot It I think that's really the
difference between someone who's just a
little I'm a little unhealthy or I'm
using this as a defense because I don't
like how what you're doing is making me
feel versus I do this consistently and I
do it because I want to hurt you almost
in a way to make me feel better what are
some ways that we can create boundaries
and I and I say create because like it
feels like to develop them because
that's something that I never had like
answering you know what would I do if I
could do anything in my day or what
makes me happy you know when when other
people when you're relying on someone
else to give you feedback to make you
feel good because that's the dependency
is I I I feel the way about myself based
on how you feel about me like how does
someone start how does someone start
developing boundaries like what are a
few things that people can do to
to to to sort of have more autonomy I
would say boundaries really starts with
asking yourself every single day what do
I think and how how do I feel every
single day throughout the day you know I
always what I really teach is not just
teaching people all like narcissism or
codependency you can Google that and
really understand the Dynamics of that
it's more about like mental health so
what I was supposed to learn well first
off what I was supposed to get were
parents that really mirrored connecting
to me because I you're born with
intuition you're born with knowing
exactly what you want and how you feel
you're so connected to yourself as a
baby and then you kind of lose it based
on the mirror that you have and you know
other factors society and things like
that but when that mirror isn't the
healthiest and when no one's really
inquisitive and kind of honoring you and
teaching you boundaries in a healthy way
right not soul on you but teaching you
how to self-soothe you know how to
validate yourself those are two huge
huge huge parts of emotional health that
we oftentimes don't get and explain
those just a little bit more
self-soothed and then the other one
soothe and validate yourself what does
that even look like so validation is
that you honor what you think and how
you feel regardless of it
so regardless of how anyone else feels
or what anyone else says your validation
is how do I how do I feel about this how
do I feel about this what do I think and
what do I need right now and and
validating that that thought because
essentially that thought's coming from
your inner child
right so if I honor that then she feels
seen and heard and validated right if I
don't then I'm judging her
and then I shame her right so how many
times have we said I don't know why I
feel the way I feel like I don't want to
feel this way like it's ridiculous for
me to feel this way I should be over it
by now or something like that right
denying denying denying yeah exactly not
listening to her not validating her
you're judging her you're shaming her
um and when that happens you start to
build this um first of all divide
between you and that inner self right
and there's no trust there so now she
starts to shut up so when she does feel
something and this is called suppression
she just doesn't say anything she just
keeps it down keeps it down
and then all of a sudden you know you'll
have like a meltdown you're like what
happened I don't even know what happened
to me
and it's like well you haven't really
been listening to yourself you haven't
really been validating yourself in the
ability to self-soothe is different for
everyone and I see those people all the
time if you're in the store and you're
waiting in line people are going like
this they're going from side to side
they're soothing themselves they don't
even probably realize that they're doing
it but they are the nervous leg that
kind of you know the twitching whatever
obviously that's a nervous twitch but
there's some kind of soothing that that
person's doing to kind of calm
themselves down yeah so you kind of have
to find you know like what works for you
you're not going to sit there you know
on a first date and be like oh my God I
love myself okay just be a little
anxious right now don't worry about
himself soothing so you kind of have to
figure out and you really get to know
yourself in this process of like hey
like what can I do that would make you
feel better you know and having those
kind of like internal conversations you
really get to learn about yourself and
like who you are and what makes you feel
good and honoring that and it's kind of
you know I tell people all the time
whether they have children or not you
are essentially learning how to babysit
yourself or to parent yourself so if I
said hey we're gonna end this and you're
gonna have a seven-year-old with you
within the next three months or a
five-year-old or a two-year-old or a 14
year old and now you have to parent
based on where that child's at and look
at all the things that you just
naturally will give her that you just
don't give yourself and and it's it's
it's a practice but the more you do it
not sound cliche that the better you get
at it but you start to feel better too
yeah talk more about the inner child
because I've probably found the most
amount of growth and Clarity with that
connection
um in fact like I had a um a really cool
EMDR experience which I'm a big big fan
of
um where it was sort of like a conflict
a dynamic and the information was
basically just that you know my inner
child has been afraid that I don't talk
to her trust her listen and so in this
sort of abandoning of maybe how I really
feel she would Retreat as if because she
didn't trust me and that it was and it's
not just like she's symbiotically or
she's not just some higher power that's
always in alignment she's like an energy
as well yeah and that as soon as I start
to sort of validate her then she's right
there like it doesn't take long it's not
a hard trust situation but and then once
she's there no matter what dynamic is in
front of me the information was that I
feel feel calm and okay because the
number one relationship I could ever
have in my entire life is that one so
anything in front of me is not a problem
because I'm I'm now which is what we're
all seeking the best relationship I'm in
it like I'm discussing it and I'm in it
and it was just like this it's
mind-blowing I know right experience
yeah you know what's so nice is that
life gets actually a little easier but
it's not really that hard when you do it
because like you said it really doesn't
take long like people think mental
health or self-development and opening
the window and like doing all this you
know Dark Night of the soul and like all
these really deep spiritual practices
that we're having just to find inner
peace or whatever it is that we're
really searching for even just like
manifest things
um it doesn't take long once you kind of
start this process and I tell people the
one thing that we're not I always look
at mental health is a big umbrella and I
say okay there's Mental Health on this
side and then there's emotional health
on this side and emotional health and
we're taught mental health in terms of
how to push through you know motivation
like real logical things like that's not
real and fears like we understand these
logical aspects of mental health but the
emotional aspects we don't really learn
because most of us are taught to sweep
things under the rug it is what it is
there's nothing we can do about it we
have to push through you know we're
given that kind of tough love mentality
and we miss the emotional piece and you
can't go to you can do it you got this
without that emotional validation
soothing caring love nurturing you you
need that first because that's what
makes you human
you're not a robot you're not supposed
to skip over what you just innately feel
and like you said the minute you just
start kind of listening and giving her
what she needs and and you honor
yourself and you're like you know what
it actually doesn't work for me and I
don't want to do that right now and you
learn how to soothe yourself and work
through some of the codependencies
things just start getting easier and you
feel better because you are your own
best friend and when that relationship
gets really good first of all you start
picking way better partners because now
your measure what you're going off of is
higher your standard is higher because
you have this great relationship and you
feel good that the minute you can start
to sense something that doesn't feel
good you're okay with leaving it because
you don't need it in the way that you
did before so to kind of go back to that
first question that you were asking me
about narcissism and how to not attract
those relationships number one is
education but and understanding just
what narcissism is I mean I didn't know
any of that stuff but a big part is kind
of diving into your own self and
unfortunately sometimes you kind of have
to go to the Past a little bit and dip
your toe in it and just say okay well
what happened growing up what didn't I
get what was I supposed to get and what
was it supposed to look like and and
kind of unleashing those those wounds
you know abandonment and and betrayal
and violation and you know all of those
kind of emotional abuse wounds that we
sometimes carry with us that are
unhealed you know we go to therapy and
we talk it out which is great but have
you don't realize that they actually
still kind of show up in your day-to-day
life right well and and the level might
lower right there's certain things you
might kind of attune to at a certain
level of stress or or challenge but yeah
you know as soon as you get squeezed
really hard again it's still there it's
still there yeah and so let's not judge
that you know what I mean like that's
the biggest thing I I coach so many
people that will say I thought I was
over it I thought I dealt with that and
then like 10 years later something comes
back up and it's like again I go back to
like that simplistic you're human and
you feel and I think sometimes we don't
like to feel we're not taught how to
feel and deal with those kind of
uncomfortable emotions yeah no one ever
questions why am I happy but they
definitely question why why am I sad why
am I depressed why am I worried you know
yeah totally what about that I want to
don't want to skip over the diving into
the past because I feel like this is one
of those areas that I don't feel like
everyone's clear on
um
that you have to unpack the past you
have to feel the past you have to
understand it you have to go there again
um I firmly believe that you don't have
to go there with the person because no
you know they they don't make you feel
better if I mean you know we've all been
in situations where someone said oh I'm
sorry but like it doesn't matter because
the pain is higher than what the sorry
feels like so it never reaches the the
pain point so it's not like you need
them but I believe you have to go into
the past but I think there's other
people I mean there's other big
spiritual teachers that you know you
just have to sort of create the life
that you want to move forward in the
past is the past and you know
manifesting what you want is a changing
of your reality and and and I just I'm
just curious what your thoughts are on
that and your experience through
coaching and how beneficial it is for
people to
um
alchemize an experience that was really
bad for them well I think you know and I
follow those people too and everything
that they teach is super powerful it's
super correct
um but there is an element I feel like
with the manifestation Law of Attraction
thing which 100 is valid energy is a
thing vibration is a thing if you
haven't learned about it Go learn about
it because it's real but there's an
element of I go back to that emotional
health piece that needs to happen so the
validation and the soothing that doesn't
mean you live in those spaces it doesn't
mean oh God okay I'm gonna open the
window again and we're going to sit here
and talk about Mom and Dad and how
husband did this no that's not what it's
about but it is about just accepting
that it's there you know and just giving
that little
um I hate to keep using the word
validation but it's kind of like the
only word that's coming to mind just
giving yourself the ability to say yeah
I do feel like that right now
and then you know moving through into
you know more of that kind of like you
know energy and positive thinking and
I'm a firm believer in positive thinking
and affirmations I think they're
absolutely huge especially affirmations
I mean when I started I was constantly
all day every day listening to Louise
Hay and I was just constantly feeding my
mind because I realized that the tape
was not the best and I didn't have the
tools I wasn't strong enough I didn't
have the tools to every day be like I'm
gonna do this I can do this I'm amazing
I love myself you need to feed your mind
just like you feed your body so I always
tell people that when they're going
through I mean even just day-to-day
maintenance of living you have to feed
your mind because the news and people
and situations and the weather you know
they can kind of creep in and throw you
off this like positive train that you're
on
um but you have to be able to go to the
past and say yeah I am sad today and I'm
thinking about something that happened
to me or I just ran into my ex or
whatever and I'm I'm sad like that's
okay to sit there the the balance is how
long do you sit there right like that's
kind of start what makes someone
um I don't want to say mentally strong
but where you really love yourself is
can I sit there and also get myself out
of that space if you get sad about
something
it means something
right and so what would what would how
would you coach someone through like you
know this happened and I saw my ex and I
just feel really bad and I miss them and
you know I'm not sure like I questioned
did I do something wrong maybe it was me
like what what what would be How would
how would you coach someone through
being triggered because the trigger is
still the teacher the more you don't
judge the trigger and you allow it to be
there the more it stops showing up you
know what I mean like it's when you
ignore the trigger that it's gonna keep
going there because like you said it's a
trigger it's coming up for a reason so
my biggest thing is always to understand
what are my triggers but what's the
story behind the trigger so it's not
your ex it was the story behind it so
for me my ex-husband left me for another
woman you know and now they're married
and they have children together so that
if that that was a trigger for years
with me and it wasn't her and it wasn't
the really relationship it wasn't him
leaving me or anything like that it was
what that meant in my mind or what
that's an example what was the because
this will resonate with somebody so then
what was what did you think or what did
that mean to you I think the story that
in everyone's mind in my kind of a
situation whether you're cheating on or
you're left or just someone is cruel to
you is what did I do wrong you know like
what did I do to deserve this that's
always like the biggest one
um you know I never really had the whole
like I'm not enough thing like I didn't
no I always knew I knew quickly that
this wasn't really about me it was
actually about him so like I got that
and I know some people don't get that
and they really much go within and blame
themselves a lot but there was more my
story was more of like what didn't I do
was there something that or or how could
I have been a better wife or how you
know what what didn't I just what didn't
I do as a partner you know and that's
when I started understanding that even
if I nagged even if I was like the
biggest you know you know what all the
time that still didn't warrant his
behavior and I'm I wasn't I wasn't meant
to give him everything he was supposed
to learn how to do that himself so then
I started learning about like oh I'm
supposed to be whole and I'm supposed to
be happy and know how to do this by
myself and you're supposed to be whole
and happy and then we just live life
together like we're not supposed to be
so enmeshed or I'm not giving you what
you need and you're not giving me what I
need and I think most couples especially
ones that I've coached over the years I
mean you know if you go to couples
counseling the first thing is give me
the list of everything that your partner
is doing wrong rather than kind of
sitting there and saying well what am I
doing that's causing the relationship
that I have that I don't enjoy yeah yeah
right we're always pointing and wanting
the other person to change what tend to
be the fundamental like root causes
maybe not even root because it might be
like I'm not enough I'm not good enough
I'm not worthy
um there's those kinds of like Baseline
narratives that people have based on
childhood but like what are some of the
biggest points that like what are the
what are the big big hot buttons in
relationships that bring out the most in
people what do you see I think most
want the other person to change to be
the person that they want them to be
rather than accepting who they are
number one I think the other thing is is
that we when we feel uncomfortable in
life we don't know how to deal with it
validation self-soothing getting
ourselves out of a space and so we
project that wound that insecurity that
jealousy that frustration whatever onto
our partners
so if you don't know why you feel the
way you feel you're going to vomit it
onto someone else because you don't feel
comfortable and so you have to kind of
like put that energy onto someone else
which is you know I don't know picking a
fight or dirty looks or past Progressive
behavior and then we start getting into
like the emotional abuse stuff so it's
like you don't have to be narcissistic
or a psychopath or sociopath or anything
like that you could just be that average
person who feels something say for
example the woman feels taken advantage
of because she feels as though she does
everything in the relationship and he
doesn't do anything and so instead of
she she might understand that that's
what is going on but she doesn't know
how to or articulate it and communicate
that with the partner and also taking a
step back and saying maybe I just don't
have boundaries and I'm actually doing
too much and I shouldn't be yeah and I'm
resentful exactly so there's that
accountability on her part that she's
not taking you know doing and the
communication part because now she
communicates with him he gets defensive
and he thinks like there's something
wrong with him and his ego got bruised
and then we have this conflict
what's the biggest difference between
men and women
you know I don't know I think I think
the thing that we can work on is
balancing our masculine and our feminine
Energies
I think that's what I see a real
struggle with is a woman trying to be
too masculine not sitting in her
feminine not comfortable in her feminine
energy
and a man same thing you know there's
there's a balance that is kind of off
and I think especially even like in
today's world where like women
entrepreneurs and trying to be mothers
and trying to own businesses and then
trying to figure out like okay I feel
less than because she also makes the
money and she's doing this or you know
he doesn't want to stay home because of
with his kids because of what people
would think of him you know I think
we're trying to figure out what our
roles are but I you know I think that it
to kind of answer your question because
it just kind of came up I think women
are more comfortable with their emotions
than men aren't
yeah men are you know we're
unfortunately you know we're still not
raising our boys to become men that can
say I feel sad I feel heard I'm anxious
I'm worried and they don't know how to
have that kind of inner dialogue with
themselves I mean us as women we don't
really know it either but we're we are
more emotional you know than men are and
so we can't help but for it to come out
because it'll come out our eyeballs
especially during certain points in a
month
right you just can't keep it down nah
it's gonna come out at some point
depressing emotions is not easy to do
but a man can you know because that's
what they're taught to do power through
voice don't cry et cetera et cetera so
he's suppressing any kind of
relationship that he could possibly have
with himself and he's probably not happy
I see a lot of men that aren't happy
that aren't fulfilled I see more women
that feel fulfilled in their lives than
men because they're connected to
themselves they're learning how to honor
who they are what they need and they're
giving themselves that and they feel
fulfilled in life men are still trying
to chase something I feel like and
something that feels unfulfilling to
them I want to talk about cheating
somewhere I read that men cheat stay and
women cheat to leave and I was like
interesting but first I want you to
um from your perspective articulate a
healthy masculine and feminine in a man
and in a woman this may sound bizarre
but I don't know if there's like a real
difference like you know I think that
depending on what you lead with the most
I've always LED with more masculine
energy than feminine energy because
that's just how I was raised and it was
my defense mechanism based on my
abandonment and stuff like that
um and having to be the strong one and
like all of those other things so I kind
of just like flowed into that role very
very easily I hear you I yeah I'm sure
so I've had to learn how to trust how to
let someone lead
um and I think men vice versa you know
can a man lead because as a woman we all
want a man we all you know in that sense
depending on what um uh energy you
gravitate towards you know so if it's
two women same thing you're gonna either
gravitate towards masculine energy or
feminine energy so you are wanting to be
feminine then you're going to really
crave that kind of masculine energy and
especially if you have never really had
a strong masculine energy in your life
you're going to even more crave it so I
think if we can learn how to be
comfortable in the roles that we're not
comfortable in right like mine is
feminine
um then we can have relationships that
feel very balanced so like in my
relationship there are times where I
lead and he's comfortable with that he's
not intimidated by it he's like you do
your thing girl and then there are times
where I take a back seat and he leads
and I respect him for that and so you
agree on those do you agree on where
those places are in your relationship or
does it naturally organically happen I
think I
first off you have you have heartily
respect
ing a person that's right for you is do
you looking at them
put everything aside do you actually
respect the person that they are as a
human being
how they live their life how they carry
themselves they may not be perfect but
do you respect them when people say to
me like what's the one thing that you
need in a relationship people will say
like communication or loyalty or honesty
or whatever but it for me it is respect
because if I respect you then I'm going
to communicate in a different way with
you than if I don't can you just drill
down on the word respect I just want to
hear some more around what that really
means for me it's regardless of what you
do for a living you know you leave your
socks on the floor are you a kind human
being it what you give to the world do I
look at that and say that's really
important I think that's valuable you
know like how you treat other people
yeah and you may always may not always
be the nicest but what is the consistent
behavior and really how healthy are you
you know like if you're a fairly healthy
human being this is yeah I have some
stuff I have some wounds and this is
what they are and the person even knows
what's going on inside of themselves and
trying to work on it and fix it it makes
you it hopefully it'll make you even
more attracted to the person because
they're owning it they're not defining
vulnerability they're not treating you
poorly when someone treats you poorly is
because something's going on inside of
them they're uncomfortable and they're
treating someone else unfair unkind
right because they're uncomfortable or
their self-esteem isn't there or they
have all these abandonment issue or
whatever the list can go on and on
um that's why we can't take what people
do to us personally right but yeah I
think it really comes down to just the
character of a person why do people
cheat then I think I mean I think people
cheat for different reasons I think I
think some people cheat because they
don't honor that they don't want to be
with this person you know that they
maybe the person isn't right for them
um and they don't want to admit that for
whatever reasons I think some people
cheat because they think the grass is
greener I think some people cheat
because they think that the next person
is going to be easier than this and they
don't usually and I kind of is more with
men than women when they start dipping
especially when you start getting into
like Affairs that's really I don't want
to deal with me
and so instead of not dealing with me
I'm just going to leave yeah and you
know the grass is never Greener but
there's an element of I don't want to
open this window and so I just I just
leave
some people get fired from the job I
think too yeah you know they kind of
just start to in the in in the back
office start to just really things
up you know they just start to make a
mess because they're not man or woman
enough to end something that they know
is not right so they get themselves
fired from the job yes yes it's just
it's some people it is a little bit of
of kind of like a cop-out right like I
don't want to own it maybe they don't
want to live alone maybe they don't want
to start over and so there's like an
element of all right let me try to find
some happiness here let me keep this let
me just mess it all up so maybe she'll
leave me you know if you listen to those
hay and you know there might be some
other people in that sphere do you ever
listen to Abraham Hicks stuff it took me
a while to be able to listen to Abraham
because I was like what is this woman
talking about you're like this makes no
sense oh she's channeling yeah yeah
exactly I was like she's talking to
someone I don't think it's her I don't
know what's going on I mean I think
every person like even Eckhart Tolle I
listened to him it took me a while to
like graduate to certain
you know really deep spiritual people
that are talking some stuff that you
have to really understand what the heck
they're talking about and be able to
like break it down so it feels impactful
right and then it's actually helpful
yeah so you can hear it right yeah sort
of like we can't treat people at a
higher level necessarily than we treat
ourselves we also you know can't really
hear at a level higher than where we're
at so right like I always feel like the
Journey of who's teaching you kind of
continues to spiral because you've heard
the information you get it you kind of
move on you kind of get it you kind of
go you kind of get it I'm not saying
it's higher or lower it might just be
different but yeah um but but I think so
the question I had about Abraham Hicks
content is that and I'm curious your
thoughts
she Abraham source
channels the information that anyone
could be the right person like you could
use anyone as your point of attention
for all the positive things
so
is that do you believe that from a
spiritual level do you believe that
energetically that if you respected
somebody if you focused on all of the
positive because you only get with
somebody in the beginning because of the
positive right you see a bunch of things
that you like
and you go in and then over time you
know things chip away or traumas sort of
surface triggers get activated
um uh you know sometimes you become a
little bit of an investigator for all
the things to protect you from something
that you've had happen to you before
um and look for problems
um to hedge your bets so there's all
that but do you think that it's possible
to just really really use someone if you
never wanted them to change from the way
they are you respected them could you
use them as your point of attention for
all the positive for the rest of your
life
I think is as long as you both want the
same things so for me do you share the
same beliefs and values do you want the
same things out of life so I think any
relationship can work 100 and be very
successful if you are
for me I do think physical attraction
has to be there so and that's not
something that you have to even work at
you either have chemistry or you don't
and that's totally fine so chemistry
um do we share the same beliefs do we
want the same things if those things are
there then the reason why our
relationship does not work out is
because you're swimming in that pool and
I'm in this pool and we're not anywhere
near each other
you know how if I'm going on this
journey of self-development and growth
and I'm honoring this and I'm working on
myself and you're not doing any of the
work
no chance I think chemistry and
compatibility are two really big buckets
of curiosity I was just listening to
something this morning of a psychologist
talking about chemistry being something
that can grow and sometimes after the
first date you're like oh I don't know
and I don't know I don't know if I agree
with that
yes I think you do have to have some
tiny inkling of I'm curious you know I
mean we all know we've met people on
date one and we're like no that's hard
no yep nope not there that's okay but I
do think there are those other people
there like I don't know I don't know yet
uh maybe and I've had that experience
happen to me multiple times almost every
person I've ever been with it's kind of
been like a I don't know I don't know
the problem was is that when I did know
I didn't honor it right so it was I was
intrigued to learn more and I think you
should right we need to learn about the
person before we just like completely
write them off
um but I and I so I do think that that
can grow but there has to be something
there between you and that person that
even makes you want to like find out
more so if that's not there then to me
that's that's a no
what about compatibility because God
I've made so many poor decisions of
thinking that compatibility ability was
two people liking all the same stuff and
them and being more the same and the
more the same you were the better off
you were probably gonna be but that's
not the case so like like what like what
are like some pillars of compatibility
that you go like these are the four
things like you gotta be in alignment
about these things or maybe there's ten
or two I don't know but like what is it
because I I think I'm still trying to
figure that out I'm still trying to
figure out Dental compatibility is
well I mean I don't know for me I look
at it like there has to be common
interest there has to be
you know if you if you took out the
sexual attraction right just take out
that for a second chemistry so to speak
let's not even focus on that is this
person your friend
like I'm I'm always looking for my best
friend I'm not looking for someone
that's exactly like me but I am looking
for someone that
you know do Opposites Attract yes they
do or do similar people can be married
for 50 years and they have the same
interests and everything yeah that can
work too so I don't know if it's more of
do I respect you are you my friend
really looking at people as friends and
not worrying about you know the sexual
chemistry compatibility kind of part
because that will just either be there
or it won't and yes you can work on it
but you shouldn't have to work hard in
the beginning it should be there for me
I'm always I was more so looking for my
friend
because when you know you know you've
met a woman before where like you
immediately hit it off you're like this
is my soul sister like we just clicked
it was so easy so that's what I'm
looking for I'm just looking for it in a
man with a penis that's it right right
it doesn't mean he has to go and like
get his nails done with me or do any of
that stuff no but is he my friend so
understanding like what should a good
friend be
for me and I had to look at my past
relationships and look at all of those
men it wasn't that many and um and
looking at like what didn't they what
couldn't they've provided that I really
needed them to be able to give me as a
friend and a lot of it was you know do
they have empathy
do they validate did they shame and not
needing the validation but validation is
important that's one of the things that
connects to to another human being is
that ability for me to sit here and have
empathy and sit with you in how you feel
and understand why you're feeling the
way you're feeling that's just like
basic friendship stuff right so we we
get a little in our heads with maybe
like what does it do for a living
because we want kids and yeah those
things are important but is he a good
person when I'm stressed and I go to
this person that I'm dating and I say
I'm stressed I'm having anxiety I'm
nervous I'm scared I'm worried that how
what do they do how do they show up once
you kind of understand that and you can
only understand that once you have
already started doing it for yourself
yeah meeting at the same level right
same level and then it's really really
easy to spot the person so my exes the
things that they didn't give me I craved
them because I wasn't giving it to
myself and I couldn't see that they
weren't giving it to me because I wasn't
giving it to myself
like there was such a hole there that
when I started to feel better and I was
single and I was by myself and I was
like all right I'm going to do this and
I just not sound cliche but I was like
I'm gonna actually learn how to love
myself like what does that really mean
then I started feeling kind of whole and
I felt good and then when I started
dating I was like all right I just my
aunt used to always say to me go that
energy feels good that's it don't
overthink it just go where it's feeling
good and when I would say oh I don't
know if this is the person I don't know
if I should you don't need to know
anything did it feel good did was the
conversation good can you be vulnerable
with them and then how did they show up
that's how you start to build like
um that relationship and that's how you
start to see whether or not this person
is actually right for you you won't know
that and date one you know your
intuition is almost like never wrong
even when something starts and you have
like a thought in your head it's like it
tends to be the way it goes like let's
talk about energy like
what would you advise people how because
you said if you don't know about energy
if you don't know about frequency if you
don't know about vibration check it out
you need to because it's real like what
is it about the real that you want
people to know
well I think just understanding how to
get yourself out of a low vibration a
low energy to a Higher One going through
that process of validation self-soothing
all of those things to move yourself out
of a space I think that's very healthy
but in terms of energy with another
person
um my thing was I wanted to learn the
difference between fear and intuition
right oh my God yeah right God damn it
it's such a hard one it's such a fine
line I have read everything and watched
every YouTube video Guru purse that
talks about it you know
if it's fear you don't want to do it and
I'm like I don't think that's right you
know I think you for me I think when we
get stuck on the fear and intuition we
we fear making a bad decision right I
don't want to make a bad decision I want
more and fear we fear making a bad
decision right right okay so I I said
you know what instead of putting so much
pressure on myself to know that this is
intuition that I'm making because
intuition is the right decision right so
instead of putting so much pressure on
myself to like is this intuition I just
said I'm gonna go with energy feels good
right and if something scares me but I
know I should do it I'm going to do it
and I'm going to parent myself through
it right to help myself and letting go
of the need to have all all the
decisions be right and correct in my
life so can I make a bad decision pick
the wrong person and be okay with that
it just takes this pressure off of
yourself and if you can listen to
yourself if you have that conversation
with that part of yourself that inner
child and really wholeheartedly sit with
her she's in the chair and you're the
therapist I always tell people if you
want to do this exercise you have to
learn how to detach from that voice from
that you know little voice within that
inner child so imagine you sitting here
and being the child worry fear stress
anxiety insecurity everything that comes
up right and then you turning around and
you're the parent or the therapist and
help her through what she's feeling
because sometimes she doesn't even know
what she's feeling she's just feeling
something yeah she's just worried and
helping her break down what's really the
problem here what are you really nervous
about
then you start to kind of like break
fears down and then they don't have as
much energetic pull over you to kind of
like mess with your life
so fear is making a fear is the fear of
making a bad decision fear is more
paralyzing yes yes 100 and intuition is
more action
it is more action but you know with
intuition
when she's talking do you listen and
what is she saying like I always try to
like have like a really good
conversation with her to understand like
do you really want to do this like what
are you really scared of you know and a
lot of it is pain I'm just scared of
pain
okay well what pain
and then don't get me wrong there are
times where I'm like do you want to do
this and if you listen to her if it's
intuition she'll go no that's a hard no
I don't want to do this I don't feel
like this person's right okay so what's
really going on well I don't want to be
alone I'm bored
I'm lonely I'm feeling insecure whatever
I haven't had sex in a while whatever
whatever it is right so it's you really
just have to like listen to her and have
conversations with her and she'll guide
you I'm glad you said the word sex
because I wanted to ask you about that
man it always seems like the most
prevalent indicator it's not the most
important thing you can work on that
right right but yet it really becomes
this barometer of connection
is that what you found in coaching is
that what you found in in experiencing
couples and how do you create a healthy
sex life is it an actual like thing that
you talk about agree to or is it more
symptomatic
well I mean I think different phases of
different relationships you know what I
mean like obviously in the beginning you
should be having amazing sex all the
time no fighting it's it's great and you
know as the relationship what's all
what's the how long is that supposed to
last some people are like yeah I want to
live in the honeymoon phase forever and
you should and well yeah everybody does
but realistically like how long should
you be in the honeymoon phase versus you
know versus not because it can be an
indicator of issues I still feel like
I'm in a honeymoon phase just now
there's other real life that also is
here with us do you know what I mean so
like in the beginning when I was when we
were dating we weren't taught we weren't
dealing with each other's families or
your mom needs to go to the doctor or
this needs to have there wasn't life
really happening yeah kids like all
right will you go pick him up at soccer
and then this has to happen like none of
that was happening there was no stress
it was just fun times because now
there's still fun times there is not as
many because now we have life and
responsibilities but there's still
playfulness there's still great sex
there's not as much great sex as there
was in the beginning because there's
responsibilities so if you're
communicating and like Hey we're having
a date night in a while and like hey we
need to focus on ourselves I mean we're
lucky because we're both divorced and so
we kind of have built-in babysitters but
from the people that don't and they have
to like really make it a point to spend
that time with each other if there are
families and children involved it is
harder you know you have to really plan
how to you know keep that spark alive
but you know think about like during
covid when we were like all in
quarantine and like you were trapped in
the house with your husband or your
girlfriend or kids or whatever you can
still be I think playfulness is like
that was something that I said early on
when I was dating I'm like I want
playfulness I want to be 80 years old
and you still walk by me in the kitchen
and smack my ass like 100 like beef I
want to be fun you know because life's
so stressful and there's so much going
on all the time that if you can't like
just be on the couch and just play and
be silly play is something that people
get into when they're in the mental
emotional state of wanting to be playful
like wanting to have fun wanting to let
go of the stress of life so when I get
into a playful state with their person
with their person yeah so like when I
get into a playful State I make it a
point because I want to laugh right like
I want to take away I think people take
life just too seriously and I sometimes
say this more with women than men where
they're like don't Smack My Ass or
they're just like Moody and they're
defensive because they're stressed
they're tired I get it I'm a woman I
have children I have a business I
totally understand what that means but
you have to be able to own your own
happiness so regardless of my life and
kids and responsibility and stress and
whatever I want to have a good day today
do you know what I mean like that's you
know it's a more Sovereign experience in
your day so whatever the other person
isn't so what if the other person isn't
into it
um so then you're not swimming in the
same pool
so then what do you do when I started
coaching there was a woman that I
remember having a conversation with and
she said um I have a coach friend and
she works with couples and all she does
is she re readjusts their uh
relationship agreement I was like oh
that's interesting so she said they come
to me before they get married they drop
their agreement what is their marriage
going to look like who's going to work
who's going to manage the kids who's
going to do this before they have kids
maybe they come back and they redo the
agreement okay now we're having kids sex
is going to go away for a little bit
this is so they're always talking about
what kind of relationship do you
actually want and I think that's
important to kind of sit with your
partner and say hey we've been together
for a year like what do you want more of
what do I want more of and just
negotiate your contract with each other
what can you compromise with what can't
you what are you putting on your partner
to be responsible for in terms of your
own happiness versus the things that
like I said the playfulness I don't do
it for him I don't do it to be cute for
him you know what I mean I do it for me
me because it feels good because it
feels good yeah and I I also want our
kids to see a healthy relationship a
happy relationship I never saw my
parents kissing and hugging and being
playful and silly you know even though
they're you know nine and eleven and
eight they get grossed out but that's
okay you know we're not doing anything
appropriate inappropriate and they
should see happy parents that are in
love that are you know holding each
other that are being playful what do you
say to couples that are staying married
for the kids I mean I've had friends
growing up where their parents did that
and the
because I think in their mind they think
they're doing you know such a service to
the kids and they're just so not well
because they're showing them you're not
you're not kissing you're not slapping
asses you're not laughing if you're not
in a relationship you want to be if
you're in a relationship you don't want
to be in so you're demonstrating
um a lifestyle a relationship to the
children that is not a good one and I
think you know we have this like I don't
know if it started in the 80s probably
because that's really when divorce just
kind of took off but we have this thing
that like if we're separating a divorce
the kids are gonna be all screwed up and
it's like you couldn't be further from
the truth kids yeah kids always want
their parents to be together of course
but they just want their parents happy
like I didn't give I didn't care at all
that my parents were divorced I care
that they hated each other
um
so if parents are happy and they can be
separate you know yes it'll still be
difficult for everyone because their
shared time I miss Mom and I want to go
whatever but you can manage that way
easier than two people that hate each
other or two people that are together
that don't like each other you'd advise
to move on fix your own self not your
not your partner you know don't worry
about your partner and what they're
doing and picking at them work on you so
when I coach couples I don't coach them
together I coach them individually
because if I coach them together it
constantly is a what am I not getting in
this relationship what is this person
doing wrong rather than saying what are
you doing that's causing the things in
the relationship that you don't like
because if you can own your stop and
vacant on theirs you'll have a great
relationship what are the what's some of
the best things to ask yourself say if
conflict comes up like what are a couple
things that you can do to take like the
First Steps the best steps towards
resolution
why do I feel this way
and really understanding what that means
not why do I feel this way because they
did this
go deeper than that
if you go deeper then yeah you'll get to
like the root of what's bothering you
versus what you think is bothering you
is what they're doing yeah so it's not
that they left the socks on the floor
it's not that they never pick the
restaurant what does it mean when you
feel what does it mean to you yeah if
you can do that when you feel
uncomfortable before an argument then
you're already owning your stuff and
you're getting clear on what's really
going on and if you can communicate that
with the other person and they
communicate what's bothering them right
then you can start to kind of like and
sometimes you do need a therapist for
this because you need someone to kind of
mediate because you're new at doing this
you're not going to do it well when you
start to get uncomfortable again you're
going to want to push that away and put
it on that person yeah so what is the
point I love asking this question
because I'm really just curious what are
the what is the point of relationships
I think they're meant to heal us
for sure every relationship is giving
you something that is supposed to heal
you and move you to the next level in
your journey they're either doing it
through pain or pleasure do you think
that as you heal because I feel like
sort of the healing and the growth stuff
like it just seems far more prevalent
across the board than it ever used to
like let's say before the 80s you know
um
do you think that
that is meant that that it can be done
with one person no
meaning like one relationship no
okay every person and every person in my
life is again either giving me pleasure
or pain so whatever they're giving me is
giving me um like an Insight or a tool
to like go the next step in my journey
and most people give you both I mean my
son gives me so much pleasure and has
given me so much unconditional love but
you know then there's the frustration
that you get as a parent but what I mean
is it can it can you be with one person
in your life married or together can you
have a partner in life that you can grow
through all these things like it just
seems
just seems challenging to always to to
to be on a growth in a growth mindset
lifestyle and always be on the same page
is that can they help take you to the
next level like you reach one level you
get triggered can that person continue
to help reach levels it kind of boils
back down to what's the point of a
relationship is it if it's to grow and
evolve then I just really get curious
about the institution of marriage the
idea of being with one person your whole
life like is this a realistic
expectation level of human beings these
days that are living to 100 and pretty
soon we're going to live to 120. I mean
don't expect your partner to give you
everything that you need in to feel good
or to be happy in a relationship so I I
love my partner I'm in a great
relationship but that's not the end-all
be-all of Stephanie and so I don't think
it is this one relationship but I do
think that's going to just heal
everything no not at all because you
need the triggers
you know what I mean like and if you're
part say that again say that 10 times a
row say that again and again and again
because it's people get freaking scared
when things come up in a relationship
they go not the right one not the right
one yeah you need the triggers it's just
are you do you have the tools are you
ready you know like
um I don't believe my ex-husband was
ready to open the window and that's why
he that's why he dipped and I don't
fault him for that that's his Soul's
Journey my soul's Journey was for this
and so maybe whatever you want to
believe in maybe in another life maybe
whatever but
his path of his life he at that point
maybe in 10 years but at that point he
wasn't ready to open the window and
that's okay and if you if you're not
ready to open the window for whatever
the reasons are old soul New Soul not
this life's journey whatever
um and you don't have the tools to even
open the window because it scares the
hell out of you yeah then yeah wrong
person
you know you're just maybe right for a
little while maybe right for a little
well and I do believe everyone's
supposed to be in your life for a reason
100 I was meant to marry him I was meant
to learn those lessons I had this
business developed my business developed
from it I was meant to have my son
um and yeah I and I think when you have
that kind of Outlook then you don't feel
like such a victim like why does this
happen to me or why did I pick this
person you picked them for a reason and
you can't judge that that that's part of
your journey it's painful and I know I
remember listening to that stuff when I
was going through my stuff and I'm like
girl I'm not there yet
but once you understand forgiveness once
you understand why things happen once
you take a hard look at yourself and
other people you know and it's not about
blaming you but understanding these
Concepts then you kind of like release
that like anger you know bitterness or
um anything negative that you would feel
for someone you kind of like Let It Go
and then
you know you feel way better well it's
it's a effort to achieve more
sovereignty
and and and when you are then you know
things don't hook as much they just
you're sort of you're your own ecosystem
and other people can you know interact
and there can be cool experiences but
you're not getting hooked into all these
other things because you're you're like
a self-sustaining positive flow energy
being
you know one of my mantras I say it all
the time but I always say no matter what
happens I'm gonna be okay no matter what
happens I'm gonna be okay I repeat that
constantly because you have to remind
yourself that like you will you know how
to take care of yourself you just
haven't been that's the only thing I
tell you know people that I start
coaching it's you just you haven't done
it because you didn't know what to do
you're learning what to do and now
you're gonna do things differently and
when you do things differently you just
feel this like comfort of like I'm okay
you it's a it's a beautiful feeling to
be like
I am my own best friend it's I'm sure
you've heard like Mel Robbins before
where she does the whole um no one's
coming to save you you know what's going
I remember the first time she said that
I was like oh that's harsh totally true
yeah it's totally true and but it
doesn't have to be something that when
she said it
um you know for me I was like but it's
not a scary thing it's actually a really
beautiful thing you know you just have
to kind of like feel like you got your
own back you know you have to feel like
you are your own best friend and when
you really feel that then you say that
very easily like no matter what happens
I'm gonna be okay because you're your
own best friend that's beautiful I
remember when my therapist told me a
couple years ago she's only uh nobody
holds the keys for you like nobody holds
the keys to feel to healing and feeling
better like that's up to you and I cried
and I was like that's a lot of
responsibility yes
he's like well it's not just you I'm
here and you have other people like it's
but it is up to you and I think that
that is probably one of the most
important messages is like it is up to
you and like we can't fix anyone and we
can only fix ourselves and the more we
sort of tap into that that that self and
that self-talk sovereignty like the
better off we'll be
well and I'm sure you've seen this one
too Matthew Hussey he did an interview
he said in the interview you are the
only person that has been with yourself
every single day your entire life and
you're the only person that will be with
yourself every single day for the rest
of your life and when he said that that
felt more comforting so I was like wow
it just it you realize you are the only
person that really actually knows how to
take care of yourself your boyfriend
doesn't yeah right if you're not a mind
reader I mean they're an energy reader
but they don't know they don't even get
that yet no one will ever know exactly
what you need and how you feel in every
single moment only you do so that to me
is more like cozy comforting because I'm
like yeah yeah that's right no one
actually knows except for me versus it
feeling like such a responsibility it
doesn't it's it's not a big
responsibility you just have to like
understand that I'm the only person that
knows what to do and then you know
detaching from that inner child and
giving her what she needs then things
start getting easier you know and even
when things aren't easy in life because
it's not available
like I know what this is going to be
like yeah it may not be fun but this too
shall pass that's another you know I
think I always say this to show fast
because it will and as long as you
understand what to do then you just
practice it and then the sun shines
again and then you're like okay here we
go you know it's it's it's nice it's I'm
so glad that I get to teach this I'm so
glad I get to talk about it it's an
important message because it I mean it's
mental health this is what we're
supposed to learn usually we learn it
through pain
unfortunately the way unfortunately it
is the way because we don't wake up from
the sleeping sleeping darkness of
problems with you know with just like
happy-go-lucky days it's usually it's
usually always has to go through the
fire yeah yeah and I think you know even
I tell people
though you gotta do the 82 20 rule it's
like 80 of the time you should be taking
care of yourself know this stop practice
it twenty percent is the therapist the
coach the videos the whatever but then
there are days where it flips and that's
okay you know sometimes it's like I can
only give myself 20. that's all I got
today and you're relying on Mom and Dad
and friends and whatever to do the bulk
of it to kind of pick you back up for a
second that's cool as long as that's not
the majority of the time and when you're
unhealthy it is majority of the time
you're only doing 20 and everyone else
is doing 80 or you want them to do 80.
in a in a healthy healthy balanced life
how much time should you be spending
um taking care of yourself and doing the
things that you want to do the things
that bring you
um that are put you in good energy that
feel good versus the other stuff where
it's like oh I'm gonna compromise so
that I can sort of like I know this is
your need or um I don't really want to
go do this or um you know this is
challenging how much of that time should
we be really looking after ourselves
well I think if you're always having a
conversation with yourself and you're
always doing like check-ins then there
is no definitive answer to that question
right you'll kind of just like ebb and
flow you'll know when like okay I've
been doing too much I need to step away
when problems happen it's because there
hasn't been those check-ins and you've
kind of really just been abandoning her
essentially so it's like babysitting and
you were in the other room doing
whatever and then you came in and the
whole room is a mess now you're like oh
my God the kids you know got into the
flower and like you know the whole house
is trash now you got to clean the house
and take care of the kid so it's kind of
like that so if you're constantly just
peeking in you okay you need anything
and
um when I go over this with clients I
say look at it this way if you babysat a
little kid
all day what's I mean think about when
you were a child when you woke up in the
morning no matter what age you walked
into the kitchen and living room or
whatever and the first how you doing
how'd you sleep what do you need what's
going on today that was hungry are you
hungry like what do you want to eat what
do you want to do today do you want to
clear that toy it was constant questions
being curious about how you were doing
and what's going on and what do you need
and are you okay and you know and so if
you can throughout the day just kind of
pause and just do a quick check-in after
this podcast hey how are you doing what
do you need right now not just like oh I
have to go to the bathroom and that's it
but like what do you honestly need how
do you really feel and really just
starting that dialogue with yourself
then you know boundaries gets easier you
heal from codependency from that you
take better Partners like you might do
things that are stretching yourself okay
well I work 12 hours today okay I can
sense you're tired what do we need to do
tomorrow
and when she says I need to sleep in I
need to readjust my calendar do you
honor that or do you say no no we got to
keep going we gotta push take a little
look at your uh at your Band-Aid coping
mechanisms that you use your your
addiction to bypass things whether it's
working out drugs alcohol
um you know drama Cycles like certain
people like a sport whatever it may be
like have a look at what you're doing
instead of sitting in the feeling
exactly and then you know you'll start
to this that relationship with yourself
I mean that's that's huge you have you
have to if you don't then you're just
gonna feel angry you're gonna feel
depleted you're gonna go to addictions
like it's just life is really messy when
you just ignore that voice thank you so
much such good advice thank you thank
you and keep sharing all the good info
I'm looking for looking forward to all
your videos that come out thank you so
much thanks everybody for listening to
the pretty intense podcast today I hope
you enjoyed it if you like what you
heard today and you want to hear more
please click on the Subscribe button